وينضم الينا من القاهره مع السفير احمد
ابو زيد المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
المصريه مرحبا بك معالي السفير هناك جهود
تبذل من جانب مصر ما اخر الاتصالات
الدوليه التي تمت حتى اللحظه مع الاطراف
لمحاوله الوصول الى اتفاق حقيقي لوقف
اطلاق النار
هو في الحقيقه اليوم جرت اتصالات هامه
حيث تلقى السيد سامح شكري وزير الخارجيه
اتصالات من السيد جوزيف بوريل
الممثل الاعلى للسياسه الخارجيه والامنيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا تلقى اتصالا اخر
من وزير خارجيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
جميع هذه الاتصالات بتتركز في الوقت
الحالي على كيفيه تثبيت وقف اطلاق النار
ووضع ضمانات تكفل
الوصول الى هدنه مطوله ومستدامه كي تتمكن
عمليات الاغاثه الانسانيه من الوصول الى
المدنيين وتامين الممرات الامنه
التوسط الى عناصر لوقف اطلاق نار مستدام
وهذا هو الموقف المصري الذي تاسست تاسس
عليه الموقف المصري منذ بدايه هذه الازمه
من خلال المطالبه بالوقف الفوري لاطلاق
النار
والوصول الى هدنه تسمح بالتقاط
واتاحه الفرصه للحوار بين الاطراف طيب
معالي السفير ما الذي دار في الاتصال الذي
تم بين سامح شكري بلنكن وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه هل تمت رؤيه نضجت الان فيما
يتعلق بالموقف الدولي للضغط على الجنراني
لوقف حقيقي لاطلاق النار
هو الحقيقه هناك بالفعل جهود تطلع بها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهناك جهود
تطلع بها مصر مع الشركاء الاقليميين
والدوليين واتصالات تتم على مستوى الاتحاد
الافريقي وجامعه الدول العربيه واتصالات
ثنائيه مع دول جوار السودان مثل مصر وجنوب
السودان وغيرها كل هذه الجهود
بتتركز على فكره التواصل مع جميع الاطراف
مع الطرفين المتنازعين على الارض
لتشجيعهم على اتخاذ القرار الخاص بوقت
اطلاق النار وتثبيت وقف اطلاق النار دون
الخروقات العديده التي تتم حاليا كما
تشاهدي الان هناك
هدنه يتم الوصول اليها ولكن تحدث خروقات
وهذه الخروقات تؤدي الى خروقات من الجانب
الاخر والضحيه الذي يواجه كل هذا الوضع هو
الشعب السوداني والمواطن السوداني ومثل
عبء كبير بالطبع من خلال
الحدود المشتركه مع السودان واستقبال
النازحين معالي السفير هل
تنفي تحديد اليه ما لمراقبه وقف اطلاق
النار نعلم من بعض المصادر ان كانت هناك
اقتراحات اقليميه وعربيه لتشكيل لجنه يتم
فيها مراقبه وقف اطلاق النار كاجراء يمكن
السيطره به على المشهد هل من اتصالات او
قرارات في هذا الامر يعني هذا الامر مطروح
للحوار في اطار في اطر عديده الحقيقه في
اطار الاتحاد الافريقي هناك اجتماع يعقد
في الاتحاد الافريقي اليوم بمشاركه مصر
يتم تناول فيه هذه الفكره هناك ايضا
الجامعه العربيه نعلم ان جامعه الدول
العربيه
اصدرت قرارا لليوم على مستوى المندوبين
الدائمين وهذا قرار تقدمت به مصر الحقيقه
صدر اليوم منذ قليل ايضا مره اخرى بيدعو
الى وقف اطلاق النار
ويتناول مسائل عديده من ضمنها اهميه تثبيت
وقف اطلاق النار ويدعو ايضا المجتمع
الدولي لتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه للشعب
السوداني ودعم دول بجوار السودان التي
تتلقى او تستقبل المواطنين السودانيين عبر
الحدود وتؤثر التي تقدمت
به نعم نعم تم صدور هذا القرار اليوم قرار
هامل الحقيقه لانه يؤكد مره اخرى على دور
الجامعه العربيه ودور الدول العربيه في
التعامل مع هذه الازمه ويؤكد على اهميه
[موسيقى]
ادانه الاستهداف المدنيين والمنشات
المدنيه وضروره الحفاظ ايضا على حرمه
البعثات الدبلوماسيه انت تعلمين ان هناك
احد اعضاء البعثه الدبلوماسيه المصريه
استشهد في في خضام هذه المعارك وكذلك
بيؤكد ايضا على اهميه
او القنصليه المصريه في الخرطوم الان هل
قمتم باجلاء فريق الدبلوماسي هناك
مصري التواجد المصري الدبلوماسي والقنصلي
المصري في السودان متواجد في مقرات عديده
ونعمل على من خلاله على المساعده في عمليه
الاجلاء للمواطنين المصريين وايضا نساعد
رعايه دول اخرى في عمليات الاجلاء سواء من
داخل السودان او عبر
معلومات تشير معالي السفير وهي تطورات
جديده ان الجيش السوداني وافق بالفعل على
مفاوضات تتم مع قوات الدعم السريع خارج
السودان هل من معلومات حول هذا الامر نعلم
ان جنوب السودان تحاول عقد هذا اللقاء بين
الطرفين عبر ممثلين لهم وهناك دعم مصري
سعودي لهذه المبادره هل من جديد حول هذا
الامر يعني طبعا نحن سمعنا
بالوصول الى الى هدنه مطوله
نحاول ونسعى للتحقق الان من مدى نفاذ هذه
الهدنه والالتزام بها هناك تعلمين ان هناك
مبادره مصريه جنوب سودانيه واتصالات تمت
بين الصليب الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
والرئيس البكير والرئيس الباكيري طلع
باتصالات في هذا الشان مع الطرفين
السودانيين بهدف الوصول الى مثل هذه
الهدنه نعلم ايضا ان الاتحاد الافريقي
والاليه السداسيه والاليليه الرباعيه
يعملان ايضا على بهدف الوصول الى هدنه
مطوله يعني ما استطيع ان اقوله ان الجميع
يتحرك في نفس الاتجاه الدول
المباشر
بالجنرلين البرهان وحميد المصري تجري
اتصالات مباشره بالطرفين مصر اكدت منذ
اليوم الاول انها على قنوات الاتصال
المصريه مع جميع الاطراف السودانيه مفتوحه
دائما والرساله المصريه للطرفين دائما هي
ضروره الوصول الى وقف فوري لاطلاق النار
طيب رئيس السيسي اليوم عب عن الوضع شديد
الصعوبه المتعلق بالنازحين وقدوم اعداد
كبيره الى مصر من النازحين السودانيين وان
هذا يشكل تحديا كبيرا بالنسبه لمصر على
الاقل ايضا من الناحيه الاقتصاديه هل تمت
اتصالات بين مصر وبين الامم المتحده بين
منظمات دوليه لمحاوله الدعم في هذا الوضع
اولا كما اشرت القرار الصادر عن جامعه
الدول العربيه اليوم بيطالب الدول المانحه
والمنظمات الدوليه المعنيه بتقديم الدعم
للدول جوار السودان التي تستقبل الوافدين
من السودانيين عبر الحدود فهذا مطلب عربي
تم التعبير عنه رسميا اليوم ايضا هذا
الموضوع محل كان محل حوارا حوار
بين السيد وزير الخارجيه مع الممثل الاعلى
للاتحاد الاوروبي للشؤون السياسيه
الخارجيه مع وزير خارجيه الولايات المتحده
هناك في الواقع تقدير نراه ملحوظا من جانب
المؤسسات الدوليه ومن جانب منظمات الامم
المتحده والشركاء في الدول المانحه للدور
الذي تطلع به مصر في هذا الامر واستعداد
دائم لتقديم الدعم المصري خلال المرحله
القادمه لمساعدتها في هذا المجال ايضا نعم
معالي السفير بالتاكيد الكل يتطلع الى
وقفه حقيقيه لاطلاق النار تتم بعده وفقا
لتصريحات صحفيه لحضرتك البدء في مساله
الحوار والتفاوض هل تم التطرق الى مساله
مستقبل هذا الحوار خلال لقاء المبعوث
البرهان اليوم مع وزير خارجيه المصري ام
ان الجهود تتركز فقط على الهدف الاهم الان
وهو وقف اطلاق النار
الهدف الان الاساسي هو
احترام وقف اطلاق النار
طرفين في اطلاق النار الوصول الى هدنه
مطوله ومستدامه كما اشرت تسمح بالتقاط
الانفاس ونفاذ المساعدات الانسانيه
وعمليات الاغاثه هذا هو التركيز حاليا هذا
الامر يمكن ان يتطور في مرحله لاحقه لحوار
اكثر تفصيلا حول قضايا اخرى ولكن تركيز
جهود المجتمع الدولي حاليا تنصب بالاساس
على انفاز وقف اطلاق النار واحترامه ووضع
ضمانات تكفل عدم خرق هذه الهدنه في اي
مرحله من المراه نعم السفير احمد ابو زيد
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه المصريه شكرا
لك على هذه المداخله لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات